ciao ragazzi siamo finalmente giunti sto
guardando la webcam sbagliata abbiamo
finalmente giunti al video di ogni gol
come speciale 4 ae ha voluto farlo in
occasione della xi che remix challenge
che mi ha lanciato giulia penna che mi
ha sfidato a remixare il mio rapporto
con voi che cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
di solito voi vi connettete amico per
cercare ma oggi io mi connetto miccoli
per cercare voi nel senso che io metto
la parola chiave che voi mi avete
passato per cercarvi suo miglior nel
caso mi stesse chiedendo cos'è la shayk
remix challenge è una challenge che
prevede di fare un qualcosa tipo mickle
però fatto in un modo diverso tipo al
contrario in questo caso sono io che
vengo a cercare voi in pieno stile
sheikh remi prima di cominciare volevo
soltanto dirvi che se volete scattarvi
un surf i remix come quelli che avete
visto su instagram io di giulia o di
altri creators trovate il link in
descrizione per fare vostro selphy
personalizzata e detto questo passiamo
ad ogni gol ma perchè vi infatti tutti
sti mio io veramente giocare a normal fa
prendere meno infatti puoi capire non
capire va bene come suoneria di testi in
italiano
e se come fossi un politico
raga grazie di essere stati con me io vi
mando un bacio
vediamo la bella ma una foto no dai
scherzo si certo
ebbene fra questa idea forte e mezzo
cerco dove 60 va quando anche video
genova a genova vengo molto presto te lo
giuro
eri tu sei un mago harry sei un mago si
fortissimo harry ammazza voldemort tutti
ammazza c'è un altro ceset in 2 harry
design sottopiatti incantesimo non lo
sapevo tutto bene bene bene davanti ai
mi state cercando narra alle 6 in punto
volevo farti vedere una cosa tu che ti
la cache abusiva raspi e guarda anche se
ho messo male però non cusani
con i chiamate ragazzo michele luca mi
dice a luca dove siete la puglia puglia
esatto sapevo dall'accento modificata
grazie senza di voi non sarei neanche
gli è arrivato quale figuriamoci
grazie mille a voi per ogni volta mi
stessero bene mi sciolgo la ragazza
fisico siamo ritrovati anche io di aver
trovato poi ve lo giuro l'aca davvero no
perché mi è scappato ciao mi hanno
scappato prima mano scappato soprattutto
fanno schifo ma che ne so ma mi ha detto
ma non scappato subito ciao come stai
io tutto tutto bene come sia andata la
giornata ha studiato che con studia
lingue lingue all'università
ok 26 sicilia per office sicilia però
seveso che il dolori telefono ma vivete
nel castello di dracula ma una luce
accendetela che va bene che bisogna
risparmiare però almeno a lui cose mi
impegno e giusta luminosità da studio ma
com'è possibile
pensate se tappa riva justin bieber che
il casinò papa al babbo è salutatelo
ciao ciao
ma come chiesino o ma ci aggiorniamo qua
la cosa che ti voglio dire che capisci
che nella vita ci sono ingiustizia senso
che tu non puoi avere non puoi non
capisci non puoi certo c'è chi ha troppo
i capelli su quelli aperti ma stesso
fece pure turno ed a quel punto di vista
mannaggia tu sei mio cognome non so come
ti chiami quindi fa mai presentazioni
lorenzo ieri sera mi chiede la stima
molto per sé molto genti molto gentile
gara lei non le dispiace volevo
sottoporlo a un test a un test di mitiga
so che è un videogiocatore molto acuto
si può sottoporre qualche canzone di
videogiochi qualche firma vada vada da
indovino con una super mario questa
prima ci abbiamo ce l'abbiamo la seconda
o meno conosciuto tetris e dai e vediamo
questa videogioco stupendo se lo conosce
beh sky ne vada così vada così il signor
l'ultima credo da parte del testimone di
un videogioco marker anime dai dai
vado sei fantastico bellissimo il vostro
segno e simbolo glielo morto prima di
vendere sei fantastico frase fantastico
bravissimo su home i gol non ho mai
registrato una scena così fi gas da in
tutti i video di unico e compatto mai
esatta è calato stand di nostra quasi
all 8 lo spillino sappi che ti voglio un
bene dell'anima
ti seguo da sempre grazie prima che te
ne vai devi fare una cosa mi devi
lasciare la mail
il numero perché per due motivi uno
perché ti chiedo se posso metterci nel
video e due perché devi diventare mio
amico questo cioè queste emozioni che ti
escono greta a no mi sembravi
grettamente sono gaia
volevo solo farvi notare di me avevamo
fatto la prima foto da quelli che bella
firma che o perché io emanano luce via
ci ha fatto passare ha fatto fare a
bella pachebel figoli come noi avete
tutti sta reaction incredibile come se
avesse visto un alieno ma perché i miei
capelli sono messi male però non così
tanto capito hai una bellissima voce mi
piace quando parli però famiglie ok se
stai bene che almeno so ok stai bene
famiglie
allora parli e parlano i peso non avessi
tiro giorgia proprio vero non si era
voluto vedere il tatuaggio addio è un
ora e mezzo che siamo certi
stiamo molto calmi e siamo molto calmi
file e piana tisana alla rossa quali
sono più grandi di the hub escussa non
mi mette in soggezione vite follonica
davvero ammazzò alto io aspetto aspetto
fine gioco per voi io sono la donna e
disse vai che complica la vita bravo
esatto sei una ragazza e la metti sta
cover pensando
lo so che pero non ho devi spiegare due
mete milan del piano con le richieste
qua ai 50 euro e lo faccio bella ma
perché mi scappano tutti zio calmo
famiglia che somigli un po charlie pouf
ai anche microfono così esattori
io sono youtuber pero esatto che invece
il microfono ancora l'appoggio sul
bancone sono youtube era ancora indietro
come fare la foto insieme ce l'hai fra
io vedo una maschera di v per vendetta
là dietro
drenthe prendi la prendi la ma c'è
qualcuno sul divano
ciao salve spero qualcuno sul divano la
guzzi avevo visto madonna come sei
palando questa maschera
questa è la fase 1 poi la seconda fase
realizzare che sono davvero via del
urletto è esattamente così questo è
proprio il maglione all'inverno e devo
stare comodo dal caso stai anni e anni
che seguo è grande e io faccio vito solo
d'asta 6 però un po strano prova bene
vero dal 2011 al 2017 a6 sarà vabbè mi
sei stato vicino anche quando non
c'erano altre persone volevo davvero
dirti grazie per questo figurati antonia
milan confida mi la pioggia mila lorenzo
che siamo quasi mi vuoi chiamare anche
per altri cosi non lo sa io sto sempre
di sentire non so quanti anni hai ho
paura di avere le vallette 17 sono da
manette ai polsi veniva è come no se
scherzoso finora si ammala figurazione
bene raga siete parite che è successo è
stata colpa tua che ha schifato dai
maschi faceva be di testa ahimè che per
la foto ciao
stai tranquillo c'era un bel ragazzo lì
in quella foto li oggi il mio compleanno
da sai tanti auguri frate ci siamo
incontrati 20 volte la foto che mi è
piaciuta bene ne voleva dimettersi like
ti prego ti scongiuro va bene come ti
chiami con una fan page su step e allora
tanto lo metto light e ti metto live in
diretta uno grazie la riguarda prego di
ragazzi questo era lo speciale su micron
spero che video vi sia piaciuto prima di
concludere voleva lanciare la sfida ai
mets per la sheikh remix allen che
dovranno remixare un momento della loro
tornata in modo diverso ad esempio fare
colazione con zero sprechi senza
sprecare nulla però come al solito
capito che sia piaciuto cose se al
momento mi piace anche sapersi
scrivetevi e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video ma da ragazzi
[Musica]